hello everyone and welcome to the second
game we'll be showing from the official
random World Championship 2022 it is
neither of them needs any any
introduction uh as heian um uh it always
sounds funny when I say that and then I
do some sort of an introduction but uh
it feels like I shouldn't be doing it
and then you know maybe someone is
watching for the first time and they
would like to know a little bit
something but yeah just in short another
back the the reigning world rapid
champion and also uh like Peter leko
said by the time he was 18 he was
already the world rapid championship and
he already uh won the Olympia with his
team so that's I mean quite an
outstanding
result for for someone so young and the
Yani punishi the not only the the former
World Series Championship challenger but
also another uh uh well a second time in
a row World Chess Championship
Challenger only this time he will not be
actually challenging the world champion
he will be playing against the dingling
for the world Championship so both of
them truly incredible players and well
this is official random this is you know
gloves are off no no openings no no
preparation no Theory uh this is just
you know we start fighting from move one
so let's see now how the game uh
uh how the game is different from the
one that we've seen uh that Magnus
played so okay another Back start with
Pawn to the four same as Magnus but now
just a nice symmetrical Pawn to D5 by
any promise you we have pawned a knight
to G3 and now Pawn to F5 uh already yeah
creating some sort of a funky position
we have Ponte E3 and pawn to E6 now we
have Pawn to C4 and C6 sort of like if
you would have a Queen's Gambit declined
uh and some sort of um uh well uh funky
defense against uh I think it's called
what's this defense cause I'm the the
stronghold or no the uh
stone stone something with stone
Stonehenge defense or yeah something
like that but yeah it's uh similar to
that and it should be very solid but
does it work in this particular setup
well it's up to Yan to show it to us
with Knight to C3 uh Knight to D7 and
now Bishop to D2 We have Knights the G6
double player just putting pieces on
optimal squares Bishop the C2 another
bit clears the path for his King the
castle Queen side and now we have Knight
to H4 Jan putting some pressure on uh on
another Beck's King side we have Pawn to
F3 and now Pawn to G5 we have Queen side
castles and now Knight to B6
uh we have C captures on D5 e captures
on D5 and now uh the immediate Pawn to
E4 his another back says okay your king
is still in the center of the board it's
time to open up some lines uh even at
the price of some material and the
answer is all right let's see let's see
uh what you got so Pawn to F4 attacking
the Knight and G3 and now uh node ribex
sacrifices the Knight E captures on D5
now can the Knight be captured not only
should it be captured it is uh the only
way for you to continue the game
otherwise what what are you really doing
so F characters on G3 Jan of course will
capture it and now it's up to another
bit to show that it doesn't work Rook
the E1 with check and King the D7 so now
Jan has to figure out how to
artificially Castle or or maybe even
keep his King in the center of the board
but that is really hard to believe H
characters on G3 attacking Yan's Knight
here Knight to F5 and now D captures on
C6 we have B captures on C6 and now just
Pawn to D5 beautifully done trying to
open up the lines of attack toward
towards the black king and even though
it seems like you could just capture
here you really can't the the bishop
pair is so dangerous here and if you
allow the position to open up I can just
show it real quickly for example
characters captures and captures uh
Queen B5 check will be a forced mate in
five let's say King C7 Bishop D5 check
you have to go somewhere uh Queen to B
for checking to D7 and now Bishop to A4
will be Checkmate look at this
uh absolutely absolutely stunning it's
okay after D5 we have Bishop to B7 and
now Queen to D3 uh preparing to open up
the uh the the D file with the
characters and C6 but also just
attacking that Knight on F5 so Knights
the D6 and now we have Knight to E4 and
this is much much cleaner than going D
captures and C6 which is also possible
but after Knight to the E4 uh it is just
uh what do you play what what can you
play here as black the problem is if you
capture a first D captures and C6 comes
and after King characters The Rook
captures on e4 and there is uh there's
really nothing for you to play here it's
uh it's very hard to even figure out and
we'll probably start running away with
the King then the bishop comes to B4 and
then I mean it's maybe possible to
survive but uh not uh not not if you
play against someone as strong as no
other back so okay after Knight E4 uh we
have the immediate Knight cap actress on
D5 by nipple but now Knight captures on
D6 and now what do you play in the game
Queen characters on D6 was played but I
will just show you what happens if King
captures on D6 because it seems like you
should play King captures on D6 uh maybe
even King to C7 but uh
why it's better to capture with the King
because now you have to be extremely
precise with white there is only one
winning line and it's uh it's a
beautiful one look at this bishop to B
for check okay the Knight is pin so you
have to move the king or do something if
you move the king then you lose the
queen so you're not gonna do that you're
gonna play C5 now you're gonna give up
the bishop captures on C5 King captures
on C5 and now you cut off the black king
from going back to the sixth Rank and
now you will just start attacking it so
how do you play this
uh if you if you try something like Rook
the G6 it's possible but then Queen to
A3 and now uh if the king moves the uh
the queen will just hang but also you
don't even have to take the queen for
example if King the C4 you can just
Checkmate the black king Bishop C4 King
to D4 and now Rook the E4 will be
Checkmate so even ideas like these uh
are possible so what you would probably
have to do is block with the Knight and
then the king hunt continues just Queen
the C3 with tracking the B5 A4 with
check King the A5 Rook the E5 check King
to A6 and now Queen to C4 checking the
V6 and A5 with Checkmate so something
like this if after Knight captures on D5
nipple decides to play King captures on
D6 which seems like a much better move
than Queen captures uh but he played
Queen characters uh maybe this works
maybe it doesn't uh okay and now he
there's really no way out but not
everybody just plays Queen captors and
H7 with check Bishop to E7 and now now
Bishop the F5 with check look at this
King to d8 and now not even grabbing The
Rook or you know playing something weird
Bishop to A5 with check and he was in
this position unmove 22 that yaniponishu
resigned in the game and what a stunning
Victory by uh World rapid Champion
another back Abdul satro of against a
World Chess Championship Challenger or
not not even a challenge or World
Championship contestant uh so yeah here
you resigned because uh if you play a
weird move you just get checkmated and
if you don't play a weird move you will
still get checkmated only uh well let's
say Knight B6 you block check then Rook
to D1 now the queen is hanging you
cannot save the queen The Rook is
hanging uh it's it's it's such a bad
position you you don't even want to look
at it I know ah but the after Bishop A5
Jan resigned and a brilliant brilliant
Victory the start of the match by kablo
satro we'll see what happens in the
other one like I said in the previous
video they will play two games against
each other in a match and then we will
see who wins the uh the mini match uh so
yeah uh that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it very nice start by Abu satro
we'll see if he can take it all the way
I would like to thank Joshua Baker Derek
Alex Williams Stephen Pryor Mr
subramanian and John shortly for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
official random World Championship until
we have a a random Champion so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day